right now this story a California father
tells CBS News he believes his 18 year
old sons alcohol related death was the
result of a fraternity hazing ritual the
Orange County coroner's office said
yesterday Noah Domingo died from
accidental alcohol poisoning
Jamie yuccas is outside the house in
Irvine near the University of California
campus where someone placed a frantic
911 call Jamie good morning good morning
Noah
Domingos blood-alcohol level was more
than four times the legal limit the UC
Irvine freshman was found unresponsive
in the house behind me after a party in
January his father says Noah was taking
part in a dangerous and long-standing
fraternity ritual the death of noah
domingo has already prompted Sigma Alpha
Epsilon to close its chapter UC Irvine
indefinitely
his father Dale Domingo attended a vigil
for his son in January it was nice a you
see I put this together you know we miss
her I miss my son she misses her brother
in a new statement to CBS News Dale
Domingo says we have discovered the
horrifying truth about Fator natee
hazing he contends the fraternity was
conducting its Big Brother night ritual
where Noah was compelled to guzzle a
so-called family drink to become part of
his Big Brother's family he says that
his wife eternities openly refer to this
type of ritual as being one of the
deadly nights
authorities say Domingo died at about
3:30 in the morning but the initial 911
call with some six hours later why is
the unconscious what happened disputing
the account in the 911 call Noah's
father says his son did not just drink
too much
he says experts call such victim blaming
tortured rationalizations authorities
are still investigating the
circumstances leading to Domingo's death
and have not confirmed that hazing
played a role in a statement the
University offered its deepest
sympathies to the Domingo family and
says his death brings an urgent focus on
alcohol and substance abuse the focus on
fraternity hazing has intensified in
recent years with the deaths of Penn
State sophomore Timothy Piazza and
Florida State University
eternity member Andrew coffee just like
other families impacted by college
drinking deaths no his father says he
will honor his son by doing everything
he can to end hazing by fraternities and
their members we reached out to Sigma
Alpha Epsilon regarding the confirmation
of Domingo's cause of death but we have
not heard back Nora it does have to end
Jamie thank you